bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille emilien cours ni quand ni
l'eau comme du cornillon qui est doctor
donc en informatique et médiateur aura
scientifique aux pales été découvertes
vous jouerez mien salut ça va mais ça va
ou top ça va top après tous les déboires
ont eu du mal à mettre en place et
l'enregistreur doc et il me reste que
toi à commencer par te présenter peut-on
parcours scolaire et professionnel
longtemps alors donc pas donc je suis
emilien g j'ai fait une thèse en
informatique mais mes bonbons femmes au
niveau mon parcours scolaire c'est un
parcours un peu spécial bon déjà j'ai
commencé au lycée je sais pas très bons
en sciences
la bio la biosphère j'adorais ça je mens
je m'en sortais bien mais tout ce qui
était maths et physique c'était pas top
et puis bah en fait mon objectif c'était
de faire en sorte de faire des études
courtes donc genre bts mais vu le
dossier que j'avais ben je vous je
m'étais dit fou je redouble donc je suis
allé au bac en touriste est vraiment aux
touristes ans j'ai pas touché un cahier
on met révision et il s'avère que les
youyous rattrapage
bon du coup mes plans étaient un peu
foiré donc j'ai battu boucher les à la
fac j'allais voir un petit peu comment
ça allait comment ça allait se passer
pour moi pour la suite et puis je
découvre un truc qui s'appelle la
filière bim
ça m'a beaucoup fait rire au début c'est
biologie informatique mathématiques
ok bon je savais que la bio c'était
c'était génial j'adorais ça
l'informatique je pense que façade vais
pouvoir me plaire parce que je mets bien
un petit peu ces thématiques là et il y
avait les maths sont les matchs détesté
ça vraiment c'était c'était ma bête
noire mais je me suis dit tant pis c'est
pas grave de surcroît je le fais quand
même et il s'avère qu'en fait j'ai eu
l'impression de découvrir la science en
arrivant à la fac donc tout ce que
l'impression que j'avais des maths
c'était pas du tout ça en fait
l'impression que j'avais de la bio même
si j'adore j'adorais ça c'était pas du
tout ça non plus l'informatique je
découvrais donc je là je me suis je me
suis vraiment éclaté en licence et puis
arrivé en licence 3 je me suis dit tiens
ce serait pas mal de continuer en fait
une farce d'une lourde mais bon autant
tenter parce que ça me plaît bien
donc je suis allé en master pareil dans
le même même filière et puis là je me
laisse j'ai découvert que bah déjà au
niveau de la bio faire des manifs
c'était pas du tout ça manu comme un
robot chant donc c'était pas c'était pas
pour moi donc je me suis tourné plutôt
vers l'informatique et j'ai découvert ce
qui allait être mon futur sujet de thèse
et je me suis éclatée en stage et on m'a
dit si tu veux continuer il va falloir
demander une bourse de test donc du coup
bah j'ai demandé une bourses de thèses
et je lui ai donc pour quelqu'un qui
avait décidé de faire des études course
assure un peu raté voilà c'est ça a
complètement arrêté
comment rater ses études que du coup du
goutte à cet intérêt parce que vous ne
connaissez pas du tout l'informatique
montre comment c'était licence c'est ça
ouais bah je connaissais pas du tout en
gros je le savais qu'il y avait des
histoires de programmation des machins
comme ça mais je n'avais jamais touché
ça de ma vie et est en fait j'ai
découvert ça vraiment premier semestre
de la première année de licence
j'ai eu un magnifique effet eureka
d'ailleurs cependant ce à dire que nous
à bas en gros la cour pour autant tout
le semestre dont on a jamais j'avais
appris à programmer en java en prend
tous premiers skis car un peu un peu
rude quand on connaît pas et j'ai j'ai
galéré tout le semestre
je pensais mais je comprenais pas ça
marchait pas je voyais pas pourquoi mais
mais mais exercice fonctionne femme et
mes programmes compilait pas et puis un
quart d'heure à la fin du dernier examen
régulièrement je nettoierai cet examen
mais un quart d'heure avant la fin le
prof dit un truc mais complètement
anodin qui avait pratiquement pas de
rapport avec le sujet en lui même c'est
vraiment sur un élément de l'examen et
là j'ai senti que ça a fait tilt et le
sommet suivant programmation j'ai eu
vent c'était quoi le truc qui a fait
titre c'est quoi je me souviens plus je
serai plus que ça va je te dire ce que
c'est mais c'était vraiment le ça y est
j'ai compris assez fou du coup depuis je
m'éclate ont progressé c'est un moyen
sacrés qui est juste géniale ou c'est
moi qui ai été un déclic mais
je sais qu'à cet élément-là qui a
déclenché quelque chose mais en gros ça
s'est fait balayer par le par le
sentiment quoi il est pas qu on était un
peu frustrant de savoir qui intrigue qui
tâche qu'il y avait un déclic mais tu
sais pas c'est quoi c'est pas frustrant
parce que je sais qu'il est parfaitement
anodin en fait c'est pour moi je vois
vraiment comme quand tu apprends quelque
chose je vends ce geab sont que ça
marche particulièrement dans le cas de
la de la programmation quand tu apprends
qu à faire quelque chose tu va ajouter
des petits éléments que tu arrives pas
forcément à bien connectés les uns avec
les autres et il ya un moment tu vas
place est l'élément qui fait que tout va
se connecter mais donc il ya quelque
chose de global en fait tu te serais
quelque chose de global alors qu'avant
que tu avais que des petits bouts des
petits morceaux de connaissances quoi
qu'il en soit il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'importance c'est juste la dernière
brique en fait j'aimerais qu'il ya un
petit peu un inculte de s'émouvoir parce
que c'est quand même des moments où
quand tu sens que tu as compris ceux
passés fou que c'est ça surtout gagner
certains poissons viandes mais du coup
pour moi c'est un truc qui m'obsède
cassé j'ai dit mais comment ça se fait
qu'à ce moment là j'ai compris quelque
chose savoir que j'ai lutté pendant
longtemps qu est ce qu est ce qui a créé
le déclic du coup quand quand ça arrive
moi j'essaie de bons souvenirs déjà et
puis il fit j'essaie de recréer ces
moments que j'avais pas encore cette
conscience de que ça avait vraiment de
l'importance hier que ceux des fleurs et
cadeaux des faits qu'en gros on peut
reproduire parce que pour moi c'était un
truc
webb est arrivé comme ça mais ça c'est
juste exceptionnel alors que c'est quand
même un effet qu'un nom du coup je
n'avais pas capté qu'il fallait que je
revienne pour savoir pourquoi j'avais
c'était arrivé comme ça quoi ce n'est
pas encore trop tard
ouais et du coup tu t'es lancé un petit
peu mais c'est quoi ta thèse on peut pas
un peu de temps alors en gros c'était
donc c'est une thèse en bioinformatique
avait comme une grosse grosse pour
composantes informatiques
ça se place dans le contexte des réseaux
génétique alors en gros un réseau
génétique c'est il ya des gènes qui vont
être transcrits en arn puis traduits en
protéines et ses protéines là elles vont
pouvoir avoir un certain nombre
d'actions dont avoir une action sur les
gènes soit positivement soit
négativement sur soi va les activités se
sauva les inhiber
et donc en général il ya plein plein de
d'interactions comme ça qui rendent
certains certains mécanismes biologiques
ultra complexes et l'idée c'est
d'utiliser un formalisme de modélisation
de ces de ces phénomènes là qui a été
qui a été inventé par un certain rené
thomas et au cynisme aussi donc en gros
c'est un formaliste purement discret
c'est à dire que les on va discréditer
les niveaux d'expression donc en gros si
je dois aussi g10 crise avec deux
valeurs on va dire la valeur zéro ça va
être le jeune n'est pas exprimer la
valeur 1 ça va être le gêne exprimée à
fond en gros c'est un peu cette idée là
et c'est aussi ça aussi un temps discret
jacques en gros on a une succession
d'événements dont une succession de deux
passages de fat d'activation et de
désactivation de gènes comme ça enfin au
cours du temps mais on a que la
succession de ces événements là on n'a
pas le temps qui va se passer entre les
événements donc ça rend le formalisme
ultra simple et j'avais deux parties
dans la thèse la première c'était deux
avec ce formalisme la trouver un moyen
de faire une réduction automatique du
réseau génétique donc on va faire en
sorte de réduire le de réduire le nombre
de gènes impliqués dans ce qu'on a de
manière automatique sur selon certains
critères nous là c'était très c'était du
c'est très théorique 1 comme comme comme
travailler après de l'autre côté j'avais
le une amélioration de ce formalisme
purement discret en et faisant en sorte
d'ajouter une notion de délai entre les
événements dans le formalisme on fait
donc là j'ai appliqué sa du côté de la
de l'horloge biologique
l'horloge circadienne et j'ai fait en
sorte de voir si ça tournait bien dans
l'horloge circadienne tant est que c'est
un truc qui est censé tourner à 24
heures si on a pas de notion de temps
c'est un peu dommage par roman faire
quelques vers la step de partie de mes
thèses hockey la première partie a été
également arrêté biologique et quelle
faute prenait en compte la vraie
biologie ou est-ce que c'était plus
théorique la biologie elle venait de ce
qu'on choisissait comme critère de
réduction
donc là en gros c'était il fallait il
fallait se baser sur les états stables
et les cycles
ce que biologie c'est ce qui est
facilement observables d'aidé qu'on a à
juste des transitions ça devient très
compliqué parce que le réseau le faire
la résolution des résultats qu'on pourra
voir biologie vu qu'on va faire des
prélèvements de temps en temps c'est un
peu compliqué de voir ça donc là le fait
si on a un système faits sont à un point
stable
c'est pas assez facile à voir parce que
quel que soit le moment où on va le on
va vérifier ce sera toujours la même
valeur et un cycle on peut retrouver un
petit peu ce cycle en faisant plusieurs
prélèvements d'accord donc peut-être
revenir un petit peu encore en arrière
donc tu as utilisé ce qu'on appelle luc
les réseaux jane donc c'est plusieurs
gènes qui interagissent entre eux donc
cette série de travaux qui ont été faits
au préalable avant toi sera pas des béni
oui oui c'est un truc qu'on connaît
depuis pas mal de temps
généralement on utilise des équations
différentielles pour résoudre ce genre
de ce genre de problématique
mais là la broche élèvera faille pas
forcément très très connu mais très mais
super intéressante le côté tueur en
effet vraiment vraiment cool d'écart
alors juste pour donner un ordre d'idée
on considère combien gagne dans ses
réseaux gun alors là ça va dépendre
complètement de la fonction biologique
pour l'horloge circadienne par exemple y
en a une vingtaine à peu près pour le
coeur de l'horloge ça sent l'écurie
turquie peut y avoir de régulation
particulière il ya une vingtaine de
jeunes d'écart et puis dans d'autres
modèles fins savoir ils deviennent alors
là c est faire des foyers dédia des
machins où il ya un sachet chez certains
organisent par exemple pour le mécanisme
un des mecs qu'on appelle le switch et
le switch épigénétiques du fan lambda
donc chez un virus en gros quand il
insère son son patrimoine génétique dans
la cellule
il ya un il ya en gros ils sont
impliqués dans le contrôle mais le choix
que va faire le virus dans quand il va
contaminer la bactérie il ya cinq gènes
en tout genre quatre ou cinq jeunes un
glass et un petit réseau et après alors
que chaque année ce n'est pas le plus
gros et quand tu parles d'équations
différentielles ça serait du coup
on suit la quantité de chaque gène ça
ouais en gros c'est vraiment pas pour
ceux qui ont peur des équations
différentielles c'est vraiment ultra
intuitif
en gros chaque équation correspond au
comportement de la 2d gêne donc on va
juste d'écrire si le gène va augmenter
ou diminuer en fonction des ses intérêts
acteurs et donc il suffit d'en mettre
autant qu'on veut mais donc c'est assez
intuitif eu d'accord mais du coup ça
fait comme des systèmes d'équations à
ses oreilles bah oui si diana 4 passes à
flawil ce sont la norme le signe que se
dévoile à ont fait que l'on fait plus de
la simulation parce que sinon c'est pas
plus mal et failles et des
mathématiciens qui est scellé du lait
c'est l'équation où c'est vraiment ce
qu'on n'est ce pas s'il y en a
quelques-uns enfin il ya quelques
inquiétudes et un petit peu ces trucs là
mais généralement les gros gros gros
réseau c'est que de la simulation et cdc
des gens qui sont beaucoup plus proches
de la biologie que ce que j'ai été moi
parce qu'en fait ils sont obligés de
prendre en compte énormément de petites
de tout petits éléments et s'ils n'ont
pas une bonne connaissance du phénomène
savoir l'importance que va avoir chacun
des jeunes dans le phénomène ça dure ça
peut devenir très compliqué de fabrique
un réseau pas ok et donc vous n'imaginez
pas mal de jeunes qui interagissent les
uns avec les autres
lear qui régule la l'expression d'été
les autres j'aime ça
et toi tu dois être l'autre ice était de
simplifier le réseau jones s'est par
exemple imaginons que on a un gène b va
un jeune à qui va activer un jeune bébé
qui va inhiber un gène c est qui et ce
gène c'est va venir activer le gène à ça
ça fait une petite boucle et le truc
c'est que là avec cette boucle là si on
se concentre uniquement sur les états
stables et où les cycles
il ya moyen de le réduire il ya moyen
d'enlever un des jeunes parce qu'en vrai
il sert juste de deux connecteurs quoi
s'est il fait juste un intermédiaire que
ça va être intimement ce genre de trucs
ok du coup en gros ce que tu prenais en
entrée c'est notre recherche ccr c'est
un grave déjà enfin espèce de réseau de
jeunes dieux du terme grâce à un réseau
et du coup tu essayé de réduire ce
réseau qui est de sorte à avoir un
réseau plus simple qui est la même
fonction que je scooter exactement
et du coup tu y arriver et du coup ça a
plutôt bien marché
là j'ai encore et encore une publie un
peu sur le jeu même si ça commence à
faire un petit moment que je me suis pas
mis donc fondu que que j'y retourne
en gros l'idée c'est lorsque j'ai fait
dans ma thèse je
il fallait que j'avais fallait que je
vais pas les paramètres pour pouvoir
simplifier le réseau est là avec mon
directeur de média du temps des thèses
on a bossé sur un moyen de le faire de
manière complètement systématique quels
que soient nés quels que soient les
paramètres donc vraiment une réduction
symbolique pour le coup on va juste
garder les différents éléments et sans
prendre en compte la valeur et du coup
on va essayer de réduire juste par
rapport à ces éléments là et du coup
fait des réductions sans perte
il ya forcément de la perte comment il
ya de la peur d'information met en garde
on garde toujours comme critère ces
points fixes et ses cycles quand on
réduit par rapport à ça il faut un
traitement qu'on conserve ses
comportements la même si mais c'est que
les plus petits il faut qu'il y en ait
un ok et du coup ça sert à quoi de
réduire les aides viennent
ça sert à pouvoir trouver des vagues en
quoi ça sert à mieux comprendre les
réseaux génétique par exemple un réseau
où il ya je pas il va y avoir 40 j'aime
ce qui est énorme
c'est très très difficilement
compréhensible même si on utilise les
bons outils parce que le temps que
passent par exemple si on utilise du si
on utilise des outils pour pour valider
des ensemble de paramètres qui
correspondra certain nombre de critères
ça ça prend un temps monstrueux on se
tape deux semaines de calcul c'est bien
quoi et l'idée de faire ça c'est que si
en question si ce qui nous intéresse et
ses critères et à priori ça ne
s'intéresse souvent les biologistes
c'est de pouvoir d'une part réduire le
réduire le réseau pour pouvoir mieux le
comprendre sur le moment et l'avantagé
que sur un réseau réduit trouver les
bons paramètres par rapport à ce qu'on
connaît au niveau de la biologie c'est
beaucoup plus facile et si on a les
paramètres du réseau réduit on peut
retrouver assez facilement les
contraintes sur les paramètres du grand
réseau donc on vous dira ben voilà le
paramètre pour le paramètre de
comment dire de la peau pour tel gène
par exemple on sait qu'il va être entre
entre cette valeur là et cette valeur là
et à ce moment là du coup on ça réduit
énormément le nombre de possibilités et
là ça devient faisable haut niveau en
utilisant un ordinateur pour trouver les
bonnes les bons paramètres
ok ça c'est super tu as et du coup est
ce que tu peux utiliser ça pour savoir
je sais pas qu'est-ce qui est parlant de
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer si manqué un certain gène ou
est-ce que ou est ce qu'on pouvait faire
un traitement d'un certain gène c'est en
gros l'idée derrière au final à la
finalité c'est si on arrive à bien
comprendre ce réseau là globalement
assez simple tout le domaine tout le
domaine dans lequel je travaillais sait
que si on arrive à comprendre le réseau
on sait que si on a ce médicament qui va
attaquer tel gène par exemple les
souhaits les conséquences vont être
comme ça nous du coup sa fermette 1 en
simulation enfin avec ce modèle là de
savoir avant de faire des
expérimentations si le médicament on va
avoir un effet rapport à ce réseau là et
quels peuvent être les effets
secondaires
donc tout ça de manière complètement
complètement automatique l'idée c'est
vraiment d'avoir d'avoir un une série de
petites éléments qu'on met bout à bout
ou en gros on va rentrer un réseau d'un
côté et un médicament est derrière ça va
nous dire ben voilà la conséquence ça va
être ça et du coup donc pas un test a
surtout développé des algorithmes et de
théorie c'était surtout des formalités
en fait ça que j'ai fait un formalisme
pour pouvoir faire cette réduction
automatique et j'ai modifié le
formalisme d'origine de du formalisme de
rené thomas pour pour ajouter le temps
donc j'ai refait un petit peu ce
formalisme l'a donc c'était quand même
très très théorie jégou en fait j'ai
bossé avec des biologistes pour
l'application pour voir si du point de
vue bio 7 et cohérent ou si j'étais
complètement à côté de la plaque avec
mon formalisme hockey puisque les
travaux de ces rené thomas c ca et cc
travail date de quand c'est les années
70 donc ça commence à dater
du coup il ya beaucoup travaillent pas
faillir il n'y a pas eu c'est pas une
grosse grosse communauté autour de ces
modèles là moi je trouve que si on
devrait en avoir plus parce que c'est
quand même super cool et il n'y a pas
une grosse communauté mais il ya quand
même des bases avancées qui sont là
dessus donc c'est assez
ça marche assez bien quoi depuis
quelques temps il ya des outils
automatiques qui se développe pour
pouvoir utiliser ce formalisme là de
manière assez à ces évidences hockey et
du coup la plausibilité biologique
visite est bon oui au thé ben euh ouais
j'avais déjà un peu un petit peu bosser
sur l'horloge circadienne dans le stage
de bio là où je me suis rendu compte que
les manips s'était passé était
absolument pas pour moi c'est quand même
bien le phénomène mais mais là en plus
du coup j'ai bossé avec le chef de l'est
de cette équipe là franck delaunay hba
vu comment il connaît notre équipe
depuis longtemps en plus les
communications étaient assez facile donc
c'était très cool et donc ça sur les
horloges circadiennes dons utilisés que
tu rajoutes et des délais ouais c'est ça
tu te fixes et qu'en gros par exemple si
je sais que que le gène havas active et
puis après il ya le jeune bébé va
diminuer dans la théorie d'origine en
fait le on sait pas combien de temps il
va se passer entre les deux donc ça peut
être une seconde comme ça peut être cinq
heures comme ça peut être trois jours on
absolument aucune idée
il a l'idée c'est d'arriver à trouver un
moyen en changeant la nature des
paramètres de de donner ce délai en plus
que du coup si on se retrouve avec tout
les tous les événements qui vont se
passer en une heure alors que c'est
censé se passer en 24 heures sur le
cirque à dien il faut pouvoir le
quantifier du coup avec ce formalisme là
on c'est possible de le faire
j'étais assez surpris du résultat
puisque le l'horloge qui fait 20 gêne
normalement j'ai réussi à faire un
modèle avec deux gènes avec ce
formalisme là qui donnait des résultats
qui est assez fou on n'a rien on avait
le décalage horaire que fonctionner
parfaitement et payer vraiment des trucs
assez assez dingue quoi je pensais pas
que ça allait aussi bien marché
félicitations ses coups de coeur et sert
à simplifier tout le bordel qu'est la
biologie
[Rires]
c'est sûr c'est que tu suis encore ce
qui se fait dans ce domaine de recherche
ouais je regarde je garde toujours un
petit peu je vois passer des publics de
collègues qui sont assez cool j en fait
j'ai eu il ya un pote de thèse en fait
qui a repris un petit peu la fin de ma
thèse et ayant il ya une doctorante qui
arrivait cette année qui approprient la
fin de sa thèse à lui manquait plus à se
continue dans la même dans la même
branche c'est plutôt cool de voir
comment ça évolue
ok et du coup il ya comment ça évolue
questionné une perspective elle elle
passe à l'est elle passe un peu plus du
côté biologie pour vraiment voir fait
l'idée de l'équipe de bio dans laquelle
on avec laquelle on a travaillé c'est
d'arriver à démontrer le lien entre
l'horloge circadienne est censé tourner
à 24 heures régulières un certain nombre
de choses et le cycle cellulaire dans la
thématique du cancer donc en gros il est
donc on sait que que le il faut que je
retrouve l'ordre on sait que le
l'horloge circadienne influence soit et
c'est là que l'horloge circadienne
influences classiques cellulaire et il
essaie de démontrer leur démontrer
linverse qui est pas forcément super
évident d'où le fait en fait d'avoir
d'avoir un modèle qui fait qu'un cadre
de modélisation qui permettent vraiment
de de simplifier un petit peu cette
horloge pour essayer de pouvoir plus
facilement déterminer quels sont les
manips à faire pour essayer de démontrer
sa mère et comment est ce qu'on fait
pour construire un réseau jane comment
on fait pour déterminer les relations
entre hygiène bah en fait ça donc il ya
essentiellement le lait les publications
là c'est là dedans qu'on va trouver
l'essentiel de l'essentiel des
informations
donc le corps de l'horloge est assez
bien connu en fait et la grosse
difficulté c'est plutôt savoir quels
sont les gènes qui vont être appliqués
impliqué dans la relation entre
l'horloge circadienne et le succès
muller ça c'est compliqué on en connaît
quelques-uns souvent qui vont que dans
un sens et à l'idée l'idée de l'idée
qu'il avait c'était d'essayer de trouver
ce qu'ils vont dans l'autre sens ce
n'est pas donc là en gros alors que
j'avais fais moi en
en master encore lâché mon ce stage de
bio c'était que j'avais extrait d'une
base de données toutes les interactions
en fait tous les jeunes qui sont en
commun avec l'enfant qui reçoit en
relation avec le 6 le cycle cellulaire
et l'horloge circadienne
et en gros de de les tester
expérimentalement d'accord donc tout ce
qui est l'extraction de base de données
ça j'ai réussi par contre le côté macho
manipulation c'était mon avis c'est quoi
comme manipulation comment elle fait
pour tester alors là ça va ça rappelle à
ça rappelle des souvenirs assez
lointains
donc on utilise des des cellules je
serai plus avoir le nom des cellules de
des fibroblastes en fait immortaliser
way qui alors comment c'était géré ça
j'ai plus si on faisait la manipulation
génétique ou pas quoi qu'il en soit en
fait l'idée c'était de ces techniques
tech
en gros nous tiens oui c'est ça on
utilisait des sr et n'a donc en gros dés
des arn qui allaient clivé les arn de
l'horloge selon se lancer selon ce qu'on
choisissait de certains gènes de
l'horloge et donc ça c'était la manie
principal et pour pouvoir voir tout ça
en utiliser on à en intégrer dans la
dans la cellule delà des gènes de lucie
ferrin lessivé rase donc c'est un gène
en gros qui dont le but est de casser ce
qu'une protéine s'appelle à lucifer la
lucie ferrin cette fois ci qui est du
coup le fait de casser cette faute et la
génère une bimbo luminescence et du coup
on essaie de voir un petit peu
l'évolution de ces trucs là donc le fcna
son but c'était de bloquer le jeune en
question mairie et du coup en fonction
du résultat si effectivement l'horloge
aussi les ou pas par rapport à ces par
rapport à ces jeunes là du coup on
arrivait à savoir s'il avait
effectivement un rôle dans le six dans
le cellulaire et dans leur chair cadène
ok bon c'est un peu brouillon mais ouai
j'avoue j'ai pas mal j'ai été un peu
pris au dépourvu
aurait fallu je regarde les protocoles
que j'avais à l'époque en gros du coup
on cherche à modifier la quantité de
certaines protéines pour voir ça se
passe et même au niveau du gène c'est
qu'on bloquer le bloquer le
fonctionnement d'un gène donc ce truc là
se passe pendant la croissance pendant
la croissance cellulaire on bloque ce
gène de l'horloge et du coup on voit si
face au bloc ce gène en question et qui
est censé faire le lien entre les deux
et on voit si l'horloge circadienne
tourne toujours ou pas ouais si elles
tombent plus c'est qu'effectivement il
ya un effet moi il me semble que je
n'avais trouvé une qui tournait plus qui
as avait l'air intéressant et en fait
ils ont refait les manips et et en fait
non juste celle ci l'horloge circadienne
a été cassée en fait les le gène de
bioluminescence il est placé sur enfin
au niveau d'un gène d'un des jeunes de
l'horloge ok donc s'il ya plus d'horloge
ce machin aussi le plus donc du coup on
ça c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à avoir
d'accord c'est tout un monde que je
comprends pas très bien et je vais
demander au site à ce que donc avant
tout cas avant tes yeux merci d'arrêter
mais pas les mathématiques
est-ce que ça évolue j'adore non mais
vous situer les profs que j'ai eus que
gérer que j'ai eue au lycée ou au
collège
en gros ils m'ont fait ils m'ont fait
ressentir les maths comme abba il faut
apprendre des formules parker ouais ce
que je déteste vraiment et du coup je
pour ça que j'ai je détestais les maths
vraiment au lycée s'est testé ma bête
noire et quand je suis arrivée à la fac
je me suis dit c'est comme ça les maths
mais c'est trop bien
du coup j'ai découvert limmat
j'ai découvert les maths en arrivant à
la fac elle discussion en ce moment
dans lequel je me fais embarquer parfois
sur comme enseigner les mathématiques
c'est un peu embêtant qui est un peu
entre les maths du lycée et puis le
matin post bac c'est ça c'est différent
je pense à un problème très compliqué
parce que même au niveau de la bio ce
que j'ai découvert en arrivant à la fac
en bio alors que pour le coup c'était un
domaine que j'adorais je comprenais
vraiment bien j'avais déjà fait des
super bonne note
en arrivant à la fin je me suis dit ah
mais en fait la bio c'est pas du tout ce
que j'avais bon c est ainsi j'ai en fait
j'étais dans l'est dans les deux
premières heures dans fille que j'ai eue
de ma première année fac je me suis dit
mais j'ai l'impression d'avoir appris
plus de choses dans deux heures que dans
la totalité de la terminale est
évidemment faux c'était qu'une
impression mais ça donne quand même
vraiment cette impression la compagnie
et du coup aussi la biotech a préféré ça
ouais j'ai trouvé ça vachement plus
intéressant parce que on voit enfin j'ai
beaucoup plus distinguer la complexité
que la bio pouvait représenter
clairement c'est ça qui est que ça que
j'adore dans le la biologie plaît et je
pense que c'est lié aux cours aussi lire
et toi je le veux je pensais moi je
pense que j'ai acquis de la maturité
donc j'ai commencé à comprendre certain
nombre de choses et après je pense que
les contraintes de programmes du lycée
font qu' il n'y a pas tant l'occasion de
montrer ce genre de chose quoi ouais
c'est pas évident si on peut revenir à
tout à perdre d'autres de recherche
l'été a bien aimé la recherche
franchement j'ai bien aimé ce qui m'a
face qui m'a un petit peu refroidi sur
la fin de la thèse c'est plus le fait de
galérer des années pour trouver un poste
sans avoir un salaire de dengue derrière
évidemment est un peu le système de
publication qui était quand même très
compliqué encore en informatique ont été
plutôt bien lotis mais voilà du coup ça
c'est vrai que ça m'a un peu fou un peu
refroidi
quand j'ai cherché les cherchez un poste
à terre après ma thèse bon je vais pas y
aller pas à reculons mais je me disais
ça va être encore une année une année
est précaire j'ai pas pour me poser et
c'est jusqu'à ce que je voie une je vois
un poste à paraître pour le paye la
découverte donc là
si je vais au vert on revient en arrière
qu'est ce que tu dirais attends-toi du
passé pas un patron soit 2,8 du lycée
alors moi ce que j'aimerais bien faire
c'est aller le voit il le dira et tu
sais quoi
si tu vas faire un doctorat victor est
sacré ce serait super drôle il n'aurait
pas cru non ils m'auraient pas cru
clairement il aurait rigolé même je
pense et puis s'il voulait revenir en
arrière il parlait attend toi qui t'y
camp star cherche la thèse que jusqu à
ce qu est ce que je dirais boxe ça va
être fun
ok t'es pas trop d'hésitation ventre
quand c'est la thèse non moi j'étais
plutôt content en fait parce que parce
que franchement de ce que j'avais fait
en master 2 ça m'a vraiment plu du coup
le fait de pouvoir continuer ses je me
suis dit génial savez très bien donc ça
il ya pas trop de souci là-dessus
puis j'étais en dénudant une super
équipe bonne ambiance et tout donc pour
le coup même l'environnement de travail
était cool puis surtout j'ai fait des
cours et ça c'était trop bien avec a été
mis en scène un jeune homme en fin c'est
un peu c'est un peu par là que j'ai que
j'ai capté que que j'avais vraiment
envie de transmettre ce qui me plaisait
aux gens parce que d'accord c'est géant
j'appréhendais un petit peu quand même
le faire les cours évidemment mais quand
j'ai commencé je me sentirai assez
trouver un siège de faire signer col
alors j'ai enseigné pas mal de choses ce
que j'ai fait trois ans thèse en dc
c'est donc avec avec un certain nombre
d'heures de cours par an et 1 à terre
juste après j'ai fait des cours
d'instruction java des trous d'un détour
d'introduction des cours d'introduction
web des cours avancés en web avec php
javascript et compagnie des cours de
python pour les biologistes ce qui n'est
pas évident apprendre à programmer à des
biologies c'est vraiment pas évident
c'était vraiment cool
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait d'autres
techniques et fait des cures de
d'introduction à la modélisation pour
des biologistes aussi mais qui ce ski à
qui ça a failli qui avait vraiment envie
de faire de faire ça
du court base de données aussi qu'un
petit épais de réseau pas grand chose
mais voilà je crois j'ai fait à peu près
le tour et du goût en enseignant tu t'es
dit tu voulais communiquer la science
ouais clairement c'est ça en plus en
parallèle j'ai découvert la communauté
des vulgarisateurs français sur youtube
et je me suis donc là j'ai vraiment
commencé en plus à m'intéresser à tous
les domaines sert qu'avant je
m'intéressais en gros la bio l'info et
les maths parce que c'était ma
mathématiques mais j'ai vraiment
commencé à m'intéresser à plein plein de
domaines différents et au delà du bim 1
est allé au delà du bin voila aller au
delà du bim c'est du coup tu t'es lancé
dans plaisir notamment
voilà alors pendant la thèse en fait à
la base je me suis associé avec avec
bastien duplication bastien vergogne et
en fait on a on a voulu faire une
conférence qui mêlées et des vidéastes
et des chercheurs
un truc une table ronde autour de cette
thématique là donc la première année on
a invité la tronche en biais avec henri
broc donc un peu le papa de la zététique
en france ils ont fait une conférence
sur l'erreur et le doute dans les
sciences si vous voulez aller voir
d'ailleurs elle est sûre le sur la
chaîne youtube du plaisir festival donc
on a fait ça on s'est dit bah tiens
c'est marrant parce qu'on s'attendait
pas du tout à avoir autant de succès
typiquement on avait pris en avait pris
un amphi de sang et quelques jours avant
avant le début de la conférence
les inscriptions se sont envolés on
s'est dit ah tiens il ya peut-être
falloir qu'on prenne un amphi un peu
plus grand donc on a pris le gros amphi
de la fac
eh ben ils étaient quand même pas mal
plein et donc on s'est dit tiens c'est
marrant ça a du succès ce serait bien
qu'on fasse un truc un peu plus gros
avec un peu plus de contenu etc
donc du coup l'année suivante on a aussi
un on a commencé à monter le plaisir
festival première édition n'est ou en
gros il y avait essentiellement qu'il
faille avec eux dès que des vidéastes
ont beaucoup beaucoup de vulgarisation
un peu dans tous les domaines donc le
festival s'était pas c'était
principalement ça et du coup en
parallèle on a aussi fait une nouvelle
conférence dans le même dans le même
esprit que ce qu'on avait fait
l'année précédente et c'était sur le
transhumanisme donc là aussi c'était
super intéressant et pour le coup on a
blindé le gros amphi je pense qu'il y
avait pas loin de 600 personnes là
c'était trop cool on est super content
bah rien la conférence elle est allée
sur le sur la chaîne 2 de playa sûr et
puis du coup on a fait la deuxième
édition mais on l'a on l'a l'année
suivante on l'a un peu élargie sert qu
on a fait en sorte que ça s'adresse
aussi à d'autres personnes qui sont pas
forcément deux bases intéressé par le
par la science ou par même là le contenu
de vulgarisation et du coup on l'a
ouvert un petit peu à la communauté geek
donc on a commencé à faire à faire venir
des trucs des machins star wars etc etc
tout en gardant ce côté vulgarisation
qui nous qui me tient vraiment à coeur
et du coup ça a eu un franc succès donc
on était super content et on est parti
sur la troisième édition est la première
édition en 2016-2017 2010 est ok et
hockey et du coup la troisième édition
du coup tu l'as vu tu étais là oui c'est
aussi la deuxième édition du koweït
s'était aussi à 2010 sont ses vrais 2010
on prépare une petite l'édition 2020
donc c'est moi c'est reparti pour deux
ans
ouais ouais j'ai l'impression que vous
aimez bien aussi le café des sciences
ah oui complètement or le blog du coup
moi je suis partie aussi du café des
siens en voiture forcément mais c'est
spécial rentrée que le plaisir donc si
nous finissons dia et est donc en fait
les gens vers février et c'est donc un
peu une convention avec pas mal de
le youtube heures à pas mal de
conférences et tout ça et puis c'est
très sympa aloha fallait les deux
groupes les deux personnes à l'origine
donc donc bastien vergonnier mois à
l'origine de ce truc là on est tous on
était tous les doctorants à l'époque
donc on a vraiment un attachement à la
science en particulier évidemment mais
on globalement à la culture qui est
assez important donc on essaie vraiment
de faire un événement de qualité quoi ça
marche très très bien et du coup après
ta thèse qu'est ce que tu as fait alors
après ma thèse
donc j'ai fait j'ai cherché des
prestataires tout ça et puis je vois
passer dans le dans la mailing list du
labo une offre pour médiateur en un
médiateur scientifique en informatique
au palais de la découverte
alors le paye la découverte moi je suis
complètement fan depuis très très
longtemps et et en plus de ça fait donc
par contre médiateur scientifique je
voyais pas trop ce que c'était à terme
assez bizarre jouer ça c'était assez
étrange et j'ai aussi plein d'autres
collègues qui me transfère ce mail en
disant or c'est pour toi c'est trop bien
postuler
bon bah du coup je postule est en fait
du coup j'ai été très excellent et
franchement ce que tu veux et était
connu dans son labo comme étant le mec
qui aime une fois il me parlait grand
public
c'est ça dans mon équipe pour moi fait
je m'éclate et sur les cours je prenais
pas mal d'initiatives j'essaie
d'inventer des trucs et tout donc il
savait que ça me plaisait beaucoup
en plus vu que j'avais j'aurai je co
organisait le plusieurs festivals il
savait que le côté vulgarisation ça me
plaisait aussi vachement je
m'intéressais beaucoup donc du coup ils
m'ont transféré ce truc dans la foulée
quoi tu nous as dit que tu adores l'opel
daegu vertu peut le présenter pour ceux
qui connaîtraient pas très bien alors le
pai la découverte c'est un musée qui se
situe dans le dans le grand palais les
bâtiments du grand palais et c'est un
musée qui a un peu plus de 80 ans 81 2
ans 83 ans jouera à paris c'est à paris
oui du coup c'est à paris donc la
maintenance et un mba c'est un bâtiment
qui est mutualisé en fait c'est la même
la même structure qui fait à et la cité
des sciences et le palais de la
découverte
ils oublient les deux lieux sont pas au
même endroit c'est dans le viiième
aurait dû glisser dans le 8e
arrondissement
et donc c'est un musée qui à 80 ans qui
a été fondée par jean perrin des prix
nobel de physique dont l objectif en
gros c'était de montrer la science de
laboratoire au grand public donc ça a
ouvert en 37 g plus quelle date
exactement
et l'idée c'était de faire une
exposition de six mois si mes souvenirs
sont bons
donc si moi donc c'est un truc assez
court qui était censé après disparaître
ou il faisait venir des gens des
laboratoires pour faire des expériences
devant devant le public quoi c'était un
peu ça l'idée
et en six mois ils ont eu un ou deux
millions de personnes ah ouais vraiment
le truc absolument colossale quand j'ai
appris ça j'ai un peu halluciné cette
manière en 1937
ouais ça va barder mouvement ses sermons
l'expo universelle donc du coup il ya
aussi tout un engouement autour de la
science sur surtout à l'époque était
assez important donc ça m'étonne pas
plus que ça en fait quand on réfléchit
n'est mais voilà du coup il ya eu un
succès de dengue est donc qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont les ont laissés
ouverts le palais de la découverte et de
secours de 1937
moi ça fait quand même un peu une crise
un peu un peu une crime crise financière
et a priori ce n'était pas une ambiance
où les musées devait bien se porter donc
je me bats je pense qu'un truc
enfin un truc nouveau qui montre la
science de laboratoire qui en général
pour les gens est assez mystérieuse mais
voilà du coup je pense que ça a du
talent a dû plaire surtout bas
gm sont qu'à l'époque la science avait
quand même une image de genre c'est le
futur c'est ça va être trop bien parce
qu'à la science on va faire des trucs de
dingue je pense qu'il ya aussi cet
engouement qui a dû participer au succès
de du déni la découverte est depuis en
fait cédé en fait c'est chaque fois
c'est des scientifiques des domaines en
particulier vrai typiquement dans
l'unité d'informatique du palais là où
je suis on est tous les trois
informaticiens à tous les trois des
doctorats dans ces domaines et voilà
parés pour la bio pareil pour la
physique favron on est on est vraiment
des scientifiques du domaine ce qui est
ce qui apporte quand même pas mal de pas
mal de cacher au musée et c'est un des
rares musées on peut discuter avec des
gens qui connaissent vraiment ce domaine
là et il ya des meilleurs groupes des
exposés sur les thématiques un peu
toutes les thématiques tout là
journée c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel et l'informatique
en particulier c'est nouveau oui c'est
très nouveau
ça alors l'unité à un peu plus de deux
ans moi je suis pas arrivé au tout début
je suis arrivé un petit peu après et la
salle d'informatique elle a un peu plus
d'un an n'est donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de tout nouveau et c'est
cool que l'informatique soir c'est clair
non plus en plus avec l'un avec le la
réforme du lycée du lycée qui fait qu'il
y avait alors beaucoup plus
d'informatique donnez dans les cours et
que ces terrains c'est pas plus mal
qu'on ait son propre et ça ou scolaire
qui va nous parler du coup ça consiste
en quoi le métier de médiateur
scientifique au père et à découvrir
alors principalement sait faire des
exposés de 50 minutes une heure chacun
sur toutes sortes de thématiques en
fonction de base de nos envies pendant
les vacances et les week-ends on dira
tiens j'ai envie de faire j'ai envie de
parler de ce truc là
et au niveau des abbés selon les
réservations que nous pouvons nous faire
les groupes qui viennent donc ça c'est
le principe
le boulou principal le reste du temps on
va préparer les exploser évidemment mais
c'est vraiment que ça détruit cassé
intuitive tout ça deux ans fait en
vulgarisation parce qu on a à peu près
tous les publics va peut-être pas les
enfants mais en gros
enfin quand je fais un exposé sur les
robots est typiquement je commence
vraiment à avoir des enfants donc là ça
devient un peu plus compliqué de rendre
les choses abordables mais ça marche
toujours un toujours assez bien et donc
on a donc on prépare les exposés on va
aussi essayer d'inventer des manips on
va essayer de travailler en petits peut
être typiquement avec la direction des
expositions de d'universcience donc une
version c'est pas eu la découverte est
cité des sciences on va pouvoir aussi
inventer des manu qu'on va pouvoir
mettre dans la salle on essaie vraiment
de de trouver les moyens de transmettre
ce qui est l'informatique avec
ce qu'on peut pour pouvoir vraiment le
rendre le truc intuitif
ok mais du coup qu'est ce qu'on apprend
sur l'informatique en allons plaider
découverte tout on va on va avoir
plusieurs
on va avoir plusieurs exposés
typiquement donc on a un exposé qui
assez générales sur base caisse que
l'informatique on a parlé des données on
va pas les algorithmes c'est très très
général n'y a pas de technique dedans on
a un exposé sur la modélisation donc là
suis là je m'éclate ans et pour moi
c'est mon domaine de prédilection donc
c'est génial car il a un nom assez drôle
il s'appelle des zombies aux étoiles non
parce que dedans on va parler de
montrouge présente un modèle de zombies
d'invasion de zombies
donc c'est cool c'est un super moyen
pour parler d'épidémiologie c'est ça
marche tout seul
voilà on a un exposé sur internet
comment fonctionne comment ça fonctionne
d'où ça vient un petit peu l'historique
en un exposé sur l'intelligence
artificielle évidemment c'est un de mes
préférés aussi un truc sur la robotique
là on a des robots assez cool on a on a
une reproduction unique au monde du tout
premier robot qui a été fait robot
d'avril réflexion scientifique
c'est un peu bizarre cette notion de
reproduction unique au monde
en fait évidemment le robot d'origine je
sais même pas s'il y en a s'il existe
encore mais on a reproduit la forme
qu'il avait à l'époque de même taille
depuis qu'ils ressemblent énormément la
seule différence c'est que ben on a un
petit peu modernisé parce que ben ce
robot là ils étaient faits en 1912 donc
sans ordinateur évidemment c'était un
système électromécanique et ce qui sait
ce qu en ce que ce qu'il ce qu'ont fait
les ingénieurs qui ont bossé pour nous
là c'est qu'ils ont refait tout paraît
visuellement à part qu'ils ont mais un
ordinateur à l'intérieur évidemment la
grosse caisse du robot qui était rempli
de matériel à l'époque maintenant
évident il faut quand même c'est plus
facile
le programme qui correspond à ce qui est
censé faire ce robot là il tient en cinq
lignes
donc évidemment les ornais tendance
c'est de la rigolade
on a un ordinateur une batterie est
c'est tout en ayant la des moteurs pour
pouvoir faire bouger les roues etc
c'est un truc assez marrant il fait
encore beau et en gros il suit la
lumière qui comprend la définition du
robot qui dit que c'est un c'est une
machine qui exécute un programme en
prenant en compte l'environnement
ben en fait il la lumière fait partie de
l'environnement donc si on lit la
deuxième si on éclaire un oeil il va
aller il va lice il va se diriger vers
le même côté club si on éclaire l'autre
oeil à la diriger dans l'autre sens et
du coup comme ça il va suivre la lumière
j'ai eu de la chance tu me la montrer
il est remis à rio c'est notre mascotte
si contador et ouais on a un truc sur
les données en fait en gros comment on
fabrique des données qu'elles ont parlé
un petit peu avec des algorithmes de
compression
donc c'est un truc assez assez sympa on
a un truc sur l'histoire de
l'informatique qui est très très cool
j'ai un peu découvert les soins de
l'informatique en arrivant au palais et
franchement c'est absolument génial et
voir la vitesse à laquelle ça a évolué
c'est juste colossal s'émousserait on a
un truc sur les algorithmes qu'on
présente un peu ce que c'est on présente
un petit peu la classification de la
complexe de la complexité algorithmique
ce genre de choses c'est assez cool on a
un truc qu'ils aient un truc sur le
fonctionnement en fait le calcul
numérique comment on fait pour calculer
des choses donc là on en parle de ses
limites celles exposées le plus
technique celui là on va parler de semi
conducteurs de transistors de comment on
va pour faire un circuit que les
transistors pour faire une addition ce
genre de trucs donc il est assez tendue
mais ultra intéressant et on a un exposé
sur la sécurité informatique donc la
représente un petit peu différentes
méthodes de la différence algorithmes
pour la sécurité pour crypter pour jour
de ce genre de thématique quoi là c'est
un peu leur principal quoi et du coup il
est suivi un peu les changements de
programme au lycée cherche un petit peu
ouais j'ai même mon chef qui participe
un bouquin un phare manuels scolaires
pour pour moins de l'apprendre main pour
enfin pour ajouter un petit peu de
contenu de ce point de vue là et voilà
bah généralement on est on est quand
même pas mal dans l'est
pas mal dans ce que dans ce que font les
scolaires en tout cas des retours que
j'ai eu certains de certains proches
c'était c'était à peu près ça et ça
marche bien quoi le puits le talent et
combien ce qui est assez bien en plus
c'est que vu que souvent les gens en ont
assez peur de l'informatique les élèves
en particulier il faillit savent même
pas ce que c'est en fait ils ont souvent
leurs tablettes ou leur téléphone 100%
sans trop se poser la question c'est
assez cool de la raconter comment ça
marche à l'intérieur et que c'est quand
même un truc super cool là mais non ça
fonctionne quand on voit qu'on fait
qu'on peut faire à peu près tous les
calculs qu'on veut uniquement avec des
petits machins qui font quelques
nanomètres de taille c'est quand même
assez génial je trouve c'est un peu le
vertige
c'est ça et du coup vous avez des
présentations sauce spécifique adapté
aux programmes
je pose avec un délai de dire 'est-ce
que tu connais un peu les changements du
programme
j'avais regardé un petit moment déjà
j'ai pas tout tous retenus mais
généralement on maintient un truc quand
il ya un élément du programme qu'on
trouve intéressant on va là ajouté pour
voir un peu un petit peu le développer
mais l'idée c'est pas non plus de
calquer le calquer le programme parce
que étant donné qu'ils font en cours
c'est dommage de faire répétition s'ils
viennent en sortie au pas les a
découvertes dont l'idée c'est aussi de
mon de leur montrer autre chose un peu
dans cette thématique là l'histoire que
ça rajoute des connaissances qui peuvent
avoir pour connecter par rapport à ce
qu'ils font en cours vous voyez un petit
peu le les connaissances quoi ok je te
propose
qu'on rentre un peu dans un de tes
sujets préférés dans une noté
présentation préféré tenant pendant
qu'il puisse moi ils ne prennent de mes
préférés c'est l'histoire de
l'informatique et bat en gros or je
parle je pars de très très loin dans
l'histoire de l'informatique puisque je
commence à al khwarizmi ouais donc que
mathématicien pers
je crois que c'est 833 le c'est écrit
dans ces eaux là il me semble donc je
pense je parle de la en expliquant ben
allal typiquement l'algèbre essayer de
trouver des méthodes qu'on peut utiliser
un petit peu dans la vie quotidienne
pour résoudre des problèmes et du coup
j'ai introduit un petit peu la notion de
l'algorithme en disant ben voilà pour
pour résoudre un problème typiquement un
machin qu'on peut représenter par une
équation à deux inconnues pour la
résoudre on applique un algorithme voilà
c'est un petit peu dans cet esprit là
après je vais un petit peu parlé de
comment être égoïste mais qui soit dit
en passant est et le moc avec quaresma
voilà c'est ça c'est son nom à lui qui a
muté au fur et à mesure des passages de
l'alphabet de langue crie sur sa géniale
donc l'objet central de l'informatique
aujourd'hui c'est alcoa et smic
donc voilà du coup de la zone donc je
pèche par un petit peu de ce truc là
j'ai ensuite parlé d'un petit peu de
limites
le rapport au binaire que toro qui la
clarté ce système là je parle de george
boole aussi le bon le l'informatique
sans la halle jeu de boules c'est un peu
compliqué je parle un petit peu de ces
trucs-là des trucs théorie que je parle
aussi de charles babbage avec sa grosse
machine sa grosse machine pour faire des
calculs
enfin 59e programme peut faire des
calculs mathématiques il en parle un
petit peu dans le velay ce qui est un
des personnages historiques de
l'informatique préférées et puis là il
n'y fit plus eu assez épique courthézon
salle un peu un ouais bah ouais en gros
c'est là c'était l'assistante de charles
babbage est a priori de ce que j'ai lu
plusieurs fois elle a l'air d'avoir
vachement mieux compris le
fonctionnement de la machine de babbage
que lui-même puisqu'elle a bien capté
qu'on pouvait faire beaucoup plus que
juste des maths avec
un typiquement elle a imaginé qu'on
pouvait fabriquer de la musique avec
donc du coup la forme en cet esprit là
et est donc allé vallée morte à ces
jeunes d'un cancer de l'utérus si mes
souvenirs sont bons et en fait elle est
là elle harangue elle a réussi à
rencontrer les bonnes personnes au bon
moment pour se faire une place dans le
domaine des maths ce qui est assez et ce
qui est assez exceptionnel
et du coup les essais du coup c'est elle
qu'on attribue le premier programme
informatique qui comme pas mal la classe
en partir puis le plus ce sont son
document se sert en fait c'est un énorme
tableau dans l'accueil dans lequel
chacune des lignes représentent une
instruction qui est censé faire la
machine pour faire le calcul
et je trouve que le document est d'une
clarté colossal c'est ça c'est mieux que
certains programmes et créances et par
un certain voilà parfois c'est
magnifique mais voilà du coup je parle
un peu un petit peu déj parle d' alan
turing évidemment je peux pas faire
autrement
si c'est un des personnages préférés
j'ai paraît lui aussi il a il a une vie
digne des plus grandes pièces de théâtre
du monde super désemparé un fait alors n
turing du coup passé c'est le peu
conscients enfin moi je le considère
comme le l'initiateur dans
l'informatique moderne
bon il est connu par le grand public
pour avoir fait une machine capable de
craquer le système de cryptage des
allemands par enigma mais à vrai dire
pour moi c'est pas du tout le truc le
plus cool qui les fait puisqu'il a
inventé la machine
la machine de l'universel on appelle à
la shdm nature universelle une machine
capable de calculer tout ce qui est
calculable ça c'est cool juste pour
assister un peu plus sérieux je dirais
que c'est ce qu'il a fait pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale a décrypté
l'économiste comme des traîtres à
travers un coup là c'est juste que faire
la machine et c'est encore encore encore
plus que c'est ça ouais il a eu je crois
je n'avais jamais j'avais vu qu'il avait
failli certains qui estiment qu'il a
réduit le temps de la guerre de deux ans
quand même donc pas négligeable
ça fait un certain nombre de vies
humaines
djezzy c'est assez coûte une paix créée
j'ai sauvé quelques millions de vies
mais c'est pas le truc le plus fou que
j'ai fait enfin pour le coup la machine
universel ça a tellement changé la face
du monde sa folle que l informatique et
concepts de matinée vers clcc rend fou
c'est ce qu'il faut dire c'est que du
coup avant lui
en gros si on voulait faire faire du
calcul genre calculatrice il fallait une
machine particulière si on voulait je
pas à faire du jeu vidéo il fallait une
machine particulière si on voulait faire
qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir d'autres
n'importe quoi d'autre il fallait une
machine particulière en eau est lui en
ce qu'il a permis de tout rassembler
quoi une seule et puis il y avait des
projets comme ça et maïté ou en plus
c'était sur puce partie sur du calcul
analogique ne sera pas avec des beats
des heureux et des portes logiques mais
des trucs qu et c'est logique qu'il va
faire comme les vrais phénomènes
si on veut faire la physique ne prend
équation à se faire simuler un peu les
équations et aurier matière n'est en
projet vous avez fait une énorme salle
comme ça à faire d une machine à
calculer avec quelques et d éducation
physique et c'était énorme ça prenait
tout plein de pièces comme ça et puis si
on voulait changer quelque chose dans
les calculs que la machine bah il
fallait déplacer la machine et des
semaines pour pour modifier la machine
qu'aujourd'hui bomba américain
ordinateurs universels 2-6 fiction j'ai
trois lignes de code est certes
particulière
du coup je vous conseille je vous
conseille vraiment je suis je t'en avais
parlé il semblait un compte twitter qui
s'appelle accidentally compris turing
complique alors pour poser le contexte
turing complet en gros c'est un système
avec lequel on peut tout calculé ont
aussi choisi mme sarah tu me dis si tu
es d'accord avec moi et en gros c'est
une c'est un compte twitter qui poste
des tweets dans lequel on
il va mettre des public eye va pas il va
partager des publications en disant ben
voilà pardon ce truc là et turiens
complet avec ce truc là on est capable
de tout faire par exemple l'autre jour
j'ai vu il y avait insisté alors je suis
pas allé voir la pub mais il y avait un
système au tour du tricolore le tricot
et turiens complet complètement sa part
est complètement débile mais voyez ce
système là il va c'est ce que ce compte
là est vraiment génial consacré ils vont
débuter mon histoire de la fin indique
ce tract naturel dit donnant du coup ça
pas turing après jeu du coup fait
l'avantagent de turing sait qu'on a une
machine universel météorique
c'est que des maths et l'idée d'avoir un
canton à un ordinateur c'est d'avoir
caisse de voir une machine vraiment
qu'il est capable de faire ça donc là du
coup je vais partir sur l'invention du
relais électromécaniques de tubes à vide
je parle de claude shannon évidemment
avec sa théorie de l'information le fait
qu'il a transformé le l'alger booléenne
qui avec lequel on peut on peut tout
calculé aussi il a transformé l'algérie
booléenne en version matérielle et
galeries on est capable de faire ça avec
une machine grâce à lui voilà aussi
courant grands personnages de
l'informatique ensuite voilà je peux h
par un petit peu de tout c'est de tous
ces noms là je parle aussi de la
première machine lignac en 45 la
première version c'était 45 pareille
baisse et quand on voit les niayes la
taille de lignac aussi c'est absolument
génial
33 c'est 30 tonnes réparties sur 167
mètres carrés pour une puissance de
calcul qui est difficilement comparable
mais je crois que pour faire simple pour
faire des additions il est capable d'en
faire 100 milles à la seconde c'est pas
mieux qu animaux ça c'est sûr mais bon
par rapport à un ordi de manants c'est
absolument ridicule
non mais c'est quoi du coup je présente
un peu ça je présente bel
après il ya tout là même toute la minute
le processus de miniaturisation le en
gros dallaire un sens du transistor
qu'on a réussi à les réduire
il ya aussi tous les supports de
stockage genre par exemple le disque dur
qui le premier c'était une tonne pour 5
mégaoctets
en foot et deux photos dessus quoi après
c'est terminé et que du coup un truc
assez monstrueux et que maintenant dans
un tout un tout petit boîtier on est
capable de mettre des milliers des
millions de fois plus d'informations
c'est là aussi ça a évolué très très
vite je crois que c'est c'est pas loin
exponentielle il me semble à ces
derniers temps au niveau de l'évolution
de la capacité des disques durs c'est un
truc qui est vraiment très très
important ouais donc c'est génial
l'évolution de la quantité de données et
s'est passé genre le truc qui croît le
plus vite en ce moment c'est ça d'être
réhabilité ces monstres et j'avais
trouvé une photo assez génial où on voit
on voit une photo prise du du plafond
d'un hangar et en gros il dit sur la
photo il ya 54 millions de cartes
perforées capa forêts qui sont un peu un
peu le premier support de stockage de
l'information
j'avais petite carte en carton et des
trous dedans et 54 millions de cartes ça
faisait 4 gigas et en gros ça fait un
fier intérêts des dents dans un hangar
entier quoi il faut visiter un peu les
trucs du du cern
tous les trucs de stockage parce qu'ils
veulent du stockage
de grandes quantités a relativement
fiable et du coup il prend des détails
peuvent en gros c'est ça ouais ça
remplit des rentes des hangars
maintenant et la quantité d'informations
face et j'ai pas que je crois que c'est
exact et c'est même plus gros que la
capeb que le la mémoire nécessaire pour
netflix a priori je crois qu'ils aient
tempête out et netflix en se vengeant
mais ce qui est vraiment énorme
ouais et et ils ont ordre de grandeur
ça donne le vertige là aussi ces voix là
il a pris du coup je parle un petit peu
de côté est qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec
typiquement je parle un petit peu de la
de l'ordinateur qui a envoyé apollo 11
les mais les mecs d'apollon sur le sur
la lune quand on voit la puissance de
calcul et la mémoire qui avait dans
cette machine là on se dit comment les
mecs sont revenus parce que je crois
qu'un smartphone il est il ya un million
1 millions ou 10 millions plus de deux
fois plus de mémoire et il doit avoir eu
mille fois plus de puissance de calcul
un truc dans le genre
cc à ses fins c'est vraiment un vraiment
très impressionnant et en gros je
termine un peu l'exposé par qu'est ce
qui se fait maintenant donc les premiers
ordinateurs personnels le label one
l'apple 2 ce genre de truc et je termine
en disant que l'informatique c'est pas
genre l'ebit gates et elon musk on
connaît maintenant qu'ils sont qui sont
ultra connus dans ces domaines là c'est
tous les gens qui ont bossé avant en
particulier les mathématiciens mais
l'informatique on peut dire que c'est
quand même la science la plus jeune
c'est tout c'est la collaboration à
travers la travers les siècles de tous
ces gens là qui ont permis de faire ces
machines qui sont juste absolument
omniprésente maintenant voilà c'est un
peu ça l'idée que je présente un
excellent et il ya un autre exploit dont
tu veux tu aimerais par les mettre en
avant
il ya un petit peu l'ia milliards
ça c'est un des siens d'aidé
des exposés qui a le plus de succès
évidemment vachement les gens c'est très
mystérieux et en gros bon je présente un
petit peu un historique
on est en présentant les différents âges
d'or de l'ia et les hivers séparés par
les hivers du lien mais ça je j'aborde
pas je rentre pas trop dans le détail
j'explique un petit peu les systèmes
experts avec le célèbre akinator qui est
le digne représentant de ces deux
maîtres de ces domaines là je parle un
petit peu de comment fonctionnent les
réseaux de neurones parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut pas trop faire
des exposés sur la science artificielle
et sans parler des réseaux ne re ça me
paraît un peu indispensable et je
présente aussi les algorithmes
révolutionnaire que j'adore en gros
l'idée c'est d'utiliser la mécanique de
l'évolution en biologie pour trouver des
solutions à un problème c'est super
intéressant mais la nuit je me présente
plein d'applications qu'on est capable
de faire maintenant avec l'ia la
dernière en date que j'ai trouvé c'était
un truc qui s'appelle gaughan de nvidia
je passe tu l'as vu en gros l'idée c'est
de faire une ia qu'ont entraînés avec un
choix qu'ils ont ils ont pris des images
de flickr pour pour l'entraîner et tu
dessines un dessin too much ou tu dis
bah là je veux de l'herbe la jouer une
montagne la joie du nuage doit vraiment
un truc à la peine ce super moche et
l'ia est capable de te fabriquer une
photo avec les informations que tu lui
que tu le sais j'ai vu passer un truc
mais c'est super beau là ils ont sorti
une version une version bêta en ligne
donc en plus sait on peut enfin on peut
s'amuser avec
je crois qu'ils ont sorti le code de la
bêta aussi donc on peut l'installer en
local mais les résultats sont vraiment
impressionnants ça c'est tout récent ça
c'est tout récent je crois que ça a moin
et 10 en tout genre donc c'est vraiment
un truc récent me wade on essaie de
faire un petit peu de l'édition de
veille scientifique vis-à-vis surtout de
l'iab donc ça évolue à une vitesse
colossal parce que ils sauront montrer
un petit pot agence qui s'est maintenant
en fait
quelles qu'elles soient un peu les
préjugés soins du public que tu trouves
c'est erroné ou à ces problématiques
il ya la peur de l'ia que en gros mon
dieu ça va être horrible l'ia va envahir
le monde
donc moi pour le coup je suis plutôt
optimiste de ce point de vue là je
voudrais un petit peu parler avec toi
mais typiquement la singularité donc
singularité en gros c'est quand on va
quand on a une ia qui va être tellement
puissante qu'elle va être capable de
faire une ia plus forte qu'elle a priori
on aurait eu une escalade technologiques
qu'il y arrivera ce moment là donc moi
personnellement quand je t'avais dit un
jeu j'y crois pas trop même si en
discutant avec toi j'ai bougé un petit
pont au curseur vers vers toi peut-être
et donc voilà il ya un petit peu c'est
problématique là qui arrivent et j'ai
remarqué d'ailleurs que c'est s'est pas
laissée pas les plus jeunes qui se sent
qu'ils sont très occupés j'ai
l'impression que la génération la
génération 2000 en gros ils sont sait
pas trop dans la propre cas ou dans
leurs propres préoccupations
naya - influence de la science fiction
un peu sombre qui a eu avant et du coup
c'est plutôt plutôt à partir de notre
génération que ça ait conquis qui se
posent des questions quoi dubaï à ça et
après il ya un peu le côté c'est magique
un peu abc génial du coup l'ordinateur
il est capable de réfléchir
ouais donc ça en général en scène le cas
c'est assez vite dans l'exposé parce
qu'on est loin de là de l'intelligence
ça c'est sûr donc un des trucs là est là
pour ça je suis en train justement de de
développer un truc je pense que toto toi
tu as dû le voir c'est le menace ouais
ça je trouve ça génial menace angoisse
et une ia qui est capable qui est
capable d'apprendre à jouer au morpion
manière un peu automatique bon
évidemment vous allez voir pourquoi
c'est pas trés s'est pas vraiment
automatique mais elle est faite
uniquement en boîte d'allumettes en
carton et en perles de couleurs ou en
bis et c'est tout et cette ia est
capable d'apprendre ce qui est quand
même assez dingue
donc si un ensemble de boîtes de carton
avec des perles dedans est capable
d'apprendre c'est vraiment que c'est un
truc mécanique mais voilà du coup j'ai
fait toutes mes boîtes pour chiens
entraînés normalement je vais là je vais
la présenter pour la fête de la science
en octobre voilà un petit stand où on va
pouvoir faire jouer les gens pour les
pour faire entraîner lire une vidéo de
maths parker sur le sujet qui est
vraiment donc je crois que le gars qui
est inventé ça d'ailleurs c'est un
c'était une connaissance de turing il me
semble que c'est un seuil et du coup
c'est fait a priori ils ont dors
discussion lui il a fait cette ia l'un
et alan turing a fait le la machine en
papier c'est une au trias déconnecté
face en ordinateurs qui fonctionnent
assez bien mais j'espère qu'elle est un
peu plus compliqué quand même à
fabriquer que que celle là je crois que
c'est lui c'est dans une vidéo que
j'avais vu le nom de martin garner
apparaître gp sur martin garner way
martin garner c'est pas celui qui a
inventé le exact hexapode en gros c'est
sur une grille de morpion plutôt que de
mettre des croix et des ronds tu place
des pièces d'échecs et c'est une sorte
d'échec ultra simplifié dans lequel le
nom de alors oui pour le menacent le
nombre de boîtes nécessaire pour le
faire fonctionner c'est d'aller de 304
304 boîte à gérer c'est un peu compliqué
et pour l'hexagone ces 26 ou 24 je crois
donc je prends plus faciles à manipuler
quand même avec zéro point c'est le ski
une autre vidéo qui montre un peu ça de
vis aux deux mois par une gelée vue
salaire actuel c'est ce jeu c'est ce jeu
là voilà c'est ça car c'est peut-être
martin gardien qui est inventé
oui c'est me semble c'est lui qui l'a
qu'il inventait sur le nombre des
quelque chose et je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est pour ce jeu là parce que
martin garde la c1
mathématicien récréationnel serre qu'il
y a
c'est à dire que c'est un mathématicien
qui fait beaucoup de petits problèmes de
maths et qui paul pub pour le grand
public angot frontalement le prince des
deux enfants montillot les tout ça il en
a parlé
donc il y avait un peu ce c'est un peu
le michael launay de l'époque c'est un
mode est un peu plus énigme que michael
mais franck c'est un petit peu un
plastique
d'accord il a vulgarisé pas mal de sur
le sujet notamment
je pense qu'il souhaiterait pas qu'il
ait mis son nez quelque part dans ce
genre de problème même sort il me semble
que c'est lui les jeunes sous le nom de
vraiment quelque chose donc à vérifier
mais je me sens que c'est du coup il ya
eu ce que fait au palais que vous faites
que vous comptez faire et que vous
faites pas encore alors j'ai une liste
de projets longue comme le bras que je
pense que je n'arriverai jamais à tout
faire de toute façon il ya plein de
choses là typiquement donc on a un
certain nombre d'ateliers qu'on fait
essentiellement pour les scolaires mais
cet été on va essayer d'en faire en
faire pour le grand public sur la
programmation de robots donc des teams
où je passe tu vois ce que c'est des
petits robots blanc va qui ont été
développés par le pfl d'ailleurs je
crois c'est à payer pour lire sur ces
robots là donc ça marche très très bien
pour tous niveaux
c'est assez c'est assez génial on fait
un atelier sur en gros l'informatique
des branches et donc bouquin très très
bien pour vulgariser un petit peu à
l'informatique ça marche super bien mais
exposé préférées tu peux expliquer alors
en gros c'est présenter des concepts
informatique donc il se rapproche quand
même pas mal des maths parce que c'est
les fondements de l'informatique qui on
utilise absolument pas de machine juste
du papier du carton des stylos des
machins comme ça donc typiquement on a
une série de petites cartes pas de petit
de grandes cartes même où il ya un côté
noir et un côté blanc avec un numéro
deux dans donc par exemple on va avoir 1
1 1 2 1 4 1 8 et c'est que les
puissances de 2
et expliquer comment compter en binaire
aux gens avec ceux ci avec un système
comme ça où on gronde ni carte à chacun
pour les met dans l'ordre améliorant
d'un côté le 2 juste à côté
leucate apotex etc et on leur dit bah
voilà faites-moi tel nombre
du coup ils vont faire en sorte de
retourner de mettre dans le coup sur le
côté noir pour pour pas prendre en
compte ce nombre-là soit le nombre en
lui-même en valeur mais du coup là
effectivement si on fait la somme de
tous ces machins là ça donne
effectivement là cette valeur là et
après on leur dit ben en fait quand
c'est noir ça fait 1 0
quand c'est blanc ça fait 1-1 et hop on
a un code binaire pour un oui et ça
marche super bien et en fait à chaque
fois en deux minutes ils ont compris le
vénère alors que quand j'écris quand je
commence à expliquer aux gens c'est
anormal binaire je connais pas je sais
pas ce que c'est trop compliqué alors
que c'est quand même un des systèmes les
plus simples qui existant parce que ça
ça viendra d'une phobie que les gens
pour les nombres avait complètement il
ya c'est ça prometic est c'est souvent
tu donnes un exercice aux gens avec des
xy qui disent qu'ils arrivent pas et où
sa peinture en place par des pommes et
des bananes pommes quelle erreur de
belles années et la dame m'a dit pu
manger dans l'exposé avons exposé que
j'ai sur la modélisation
je présente le modèle qui s'appelle le
modèle de l'octa volterra je penses tu
pas ce que c'est c'est un modèle en gros
mots d'un modèle proie prédateur donc on
a deux équations différentielles une
équation qui correspond au poids une
équation qui correspond aux prédateurs
avait en disant que les proies elles se
reproduisent plus a plus plus il ya
deux-trois présente plus elles vont se
reproduire ce qui est assez logique que
si elle la prédation ça va diminuer la
population des points si assez logique
et du côté des prédateurs c'est de la
prédation ça ça va augmenter la quantité
de prédateurs pareil c'est logique et
s'il ya trop de prédateurs ils finissent
et finissent par mourir de faim donc
vraiment la base de la base c'est ultra
simple et généralement quand j'affiche
l'équation différentiel en elle même aux
gens j'ai toujours un a donc ce que je
fais c'est que juste en dessous je mets
exactement la même chose à part je
remplace les différents éléments les
différents termes de l'équation par des
petites têtes de moutons mignon
des petites têtes de l'union et ça passe
tout seul c'est vraiment ça c'est juste
la phobie de a revendu ça ressemble à
des maths quoi est long et les équations
d'autres cas de terrassa ressemble pas
du tout les équations du coup pour les
réseaux de jeunes ça ressemble à un
concert comme si c'est vraiment l'idée
c'est en la seule différence qu'il va y
avoir entre ses équations là et les
équations jane c'est juste les fonctions
qu'on évoque on va utiliser que seront
pas les mêmes typiquement on va utiliser
des plus tôt des fonctions sinusoïdale
pour pour essayer de représenter un
petit peu le comportement des jeunes ne
croient pas forcément utilisés dans le
cadet des modèles de d'écologie parce
qu'en fait le modèle de l'octa volterra
c'est un modèle d'écologie
ouais ouais c'est complètement
complètement la même forme pour ça c'est
assez intuitif en fait donc que je
n'hésite pas à le montrer aux gens parce
que au final même s'ils ont peur au
début ils sont complètement capable de
comprendre et dans mon livre je prétends
qu'il ya des liens aussi entre les
équations d'autres cas volterra et la
formule deux pays les bonnes idées se
ressemblent souvent oui c'est vrai plus
c'est simple plus plus on va on va le
retrouver dans plein d'endroits
différents sur des thématiques
différentes
si ces centrales c'est il a plein de
domaines
les séances sur cette histoire de
programmer son sens aux machines ou de
faire de l'informatique sans machine on
a un projet pour le prochain
festival frames avec avec la vie de
votre wii il en apparaît a été réparé
déraisonne de renouveau social où il
faudra qu il faudrait vous filmer ça
pour pour le pour pouvoir le pouvoir
après le publier et il va falloir
m'expliquer aussi quand vous allez faire
parce que j'ai un peu de mal à voir
comment arriver à faire un réseau de
neurones souvent surtout que souvent il
n'a beaucoup de neurones avec du public
s'est pressé de faire interdire c'est
parce que c'est tout récent l'idée qu'il
ya une semaine quand les détails mais je
pense qu'il ya vraiment de quoi faire un
réseau de neurones artificiels humour je
suis fan et en fait c'est ce cas c'est
que donc il y est c'est que chaque
personne jouera le rôle d'une synapse ou
fin il y aura des gens qui seront qu
chaque synapses sera jouée par un iman
d'accord il chaque match et chaque
nouveau trajet par un humain et chaque
syllabe sur le registre je pars en
humain et donc dans le calcul simple
feed forward donc c'est du gauche à
droite calcul de prédiction en fait
chaque humain à des opérations un crabe
le mans simple à faire donc les synapses
et juste une multiplication d'accord et
les les neurones ils ont juste à faire
une fonction d'activation qu'on va
prendre la plus simple possible donc un
relu pour ce qui se voit ce que c'est
donc en gros il ya juste à répéter le
message si on lui disait non de positif
et ville d'yzeure aussi donc on l'a dit
a été négatif au passé c'est une
opération très très simple et ça je
pense que ça va marcher sans problème
moi je ne sais pas je pense qu'il y aura
partie des bugs aussi à faire savoir où
et qui a foiré comme ça ça fait un peu
la pression à tout le monde de dire à ce
que c'est moi qui ai puis après par
contre ce qui était plusieurs pour le
coup c'est le
s'appelle la rétro propagation pas gai
chaîne en anglais
c'est à partir apprentissage du réseau
de neurones mais leurs poils pour chacun
des neurones c'est très simple c'est
dire que si on lui a dit 1,6 été activé
dans la phase aller donc s'il avait dit
en ondes positives dans la phase aller
alors dans la phase retour qui devra
juste à répéter ce qu'on lui a dit juste
avant le thé le message est très simple
si si on l'avait donné un nombre négatif
dans la phase aller juste il y aura zéro
au tour c'est simple pour les neurones
par contre pour les synapses à ça va
être un petit peu plus compliqué on doit
refaire sur la phase retour et vont
devoir faire de multiplication une
addition donc c'est ça c'était très
simple c'est juste de musculation une
addition que mais ils risquent pas ça il
ay ay ay à potentiel de s'emmêler les
pinceaux comme moi je m'emmêle les
pinceaux quand j'y réfléchis
du coup on va voir ce que ça donne
j'ai hâte de voir ça et puis jamais le
connais parce que ça montre vraiment que
ouais réseaux neuronaux chaque composant
fait un truc incroyablement simple c'est
sa reddition signification tout ça mais
et puis personne ne sait ce qui se passe
globalement quand il ya juste chacun sa
vision locale ou juste des vallons
message tout va bien je les fais ma bi
fication mais globalement bas le calcul
c'est celui c'est ça qui est génial
c'est la complexité qui émerge de choses
super simple voir le taux d'erreur cette
question parce qu'il ya pas mal de gens
ici à le pfl qui font les gens et le pfl
qui travaille aussi sur des réseaux de
gênes et elles réfléchissent notamment à
la robustesse des réseaux de gêne c'est
dire si tu change un petit peu les parts
mais du réseau jane ou si tu si jamais
une protéine qui pour raison ici y est
pas produite ou autant qu'elle devrait
québec les conséquences sur le réseau
deviennent à ce que ça lasse pas ça
comme comme ça chez moi j'étais pas on
sur cette thématique là mais c'est
vraiment un truc un truc intéressant que
vu la complexité des réseaux jane en
fait c'est vraiment vraiment super
important de savoir quelle langue locale
jeunes valve à avoir le plus influent
sur tel ou tel changement quel est le
truc le plus fou que tu pensais avoir
appris au cours des cinq dernières
années des cinq dernières années
je crois que c'est un peu ce que j'ai
appris sur le sort de l'informatique
parce que c'est c'est ça donne vraiment
le vertige c'est quand on voit à quelle
vitesse les éléments d'un ordinateur se
sont réduits à quelle vitesse on a
augmenté la mémoire c'est juste ça tonne
selon complètement le ver si je sais on
a du mal à croire à croire qu'on était
capable de faire ça typiquement gg on a
récupéré au palais on a récupéré un
relais électromécaniques car une
mécanique en gros c'était le petit
machin contenu qu'on pouvait utiliser
pour pas honte pour transmettre du morse
le fameux cliquer qui cliquaient qu'on
entend dans l'est dans les films voilà
c'était un peu cette idée a donc c'est
un machin mécanique c'est un truc on
envoie l'électricité et ça va bouger en
fonction du cialis ya l'électricité ou
pas
donc on va envoyer du morse on voit pop
et le truc qu'on appuie en appui à la
main avec avec son doigt sur un bouton
et pia bas ça envoie électricité donc du
coup on arrive à faire
électricité pas l'électricité un petit
peu d'électricité beaucoup d'électricité
en arrive à faire dire tout comme ça
mais voilà ça reste quand même très très
très très simple et quand on voit que on
a utilisé ses relais électromécaniques
pour arriver à faire du calcul en gros
sur le sol sur la première machine sur
la première machine de turing qui a été
fait qui a été fait vraiment en utiliser
des relais électromécaniques entre
autres et se dire qu'on est capable de
faire du calcul informatique exactement
de la même façon que quand on fait
tourner un jeu qui a un graphisme de
dengue qui font il faut qu'il faut une
machine ultra puissante on peut faire ça
avec des relais électromécaniques
alors évidemment il en faut beaucoup ont
fait on fait quand même vachement mieux
avec des transistors
mais quand on est quand on se dit qu'on
est capable de faire ça avec uniquement
un petit machin qui va bouger
je trouve ça juste complètement fou ça
envoie du bois aussi à une vidéo de
maître par carottes déjà parlé pour pour
menaces mais il a fait aussi une vidéo
où il fait des calculs avec des dominos
l'assassinât marseille ne me ferez ça la
pole parce que du coup l'idée c'est que
[Musique]
lorsqu'on fait l'informatique en fait on
envoie des circuits électroniques on
envoie des messages qui vont le nom des
fils que mais en fait si on sait juste
qu'il ya un message qui a réagi sur
quelque chose et du coup on peut
complètement faire ça avec des dominos
qui est bon le truc c'est qu'il faut
beaucoup de dominos je crois qu'il était
à dix mille dominos bon genre il me
semble ils sont ils s'en vont je sais
pas quand même temps il a passé à les
installer mais ça a dû être horrible
journée c'est peu dire ça c'est un
énorme festival un truc énorme et très
grand nombre de dominos et puis à la fin
bref on fait tomber tous les 3 dominés
au début pour faire en fait correspond
de la représentation binaire d'un nombre
donc je faisais une addition de deux
nombres de 2,3 beach accroché trois buts
chacun
et du coup c'est vrai que ça peut
marcher je crois si jamais ça apple
comme suspecte c'est rien que le fait
qu'il a réussi à faire ça et qui est qui
et qui
c'est sensé marché même si sa forêt
parce qu'avec les deux minutes façon
fait dix mille dominos la probabilité
que ça foire est quand même relativement
importante je pense qu'il ya quand même
pas la probabilité de de poser tous les
dominos exactement au bon endroit pour
sa foire pas du tout elle a cessé ses
camps c'est quand même assez faiblard
mais le fait que en fait en théorie ça
marche que tous les tous les
sous-groupes de dominos qui permettent
de faire les portes logiques
donc on roule et on va dire les les
petits petits circuits qui vont
permettre de faire un certain ceux qui
m'ont permis de faire la base du calcul
si il sait que ses portes logiques ça
marche
donc je trouve ça fou quoiqu'il cas
qu'ils soient capables de consacrer de
faire ça avec uniquement juste des
dominos des jets de pierres dans une
excellente vidéo de number five
l'expliqué un petit pot est vrai les
portes logiques à parier qu'en faire des
portes logiques avec des dominos tu vas
expliquer peut-être ce qu'une porte
logique alors en gros une porte logique
donc je vais partir d'un opérateur
logique déjà en gros on opère l'auto
lalanne opérateurs logique par exemple
c'est l'opérateur
et quand on a deux signaux en entrée
pour pour que le signal de sortie soit
positif il faut que les deux signaux
d'entrée soit soit soit positif donc par
exemple si on a 1 1 et 1 0 avec la porte
et ça va donner un zéro parce qu'il me
manque un acompte si j 1 1 et 1 1
là ça a marché parce que je vais avoir
un an sortie parce que je vais avoir
devant l'entrée donc ça va être un petit
peu cet esprit là pour ceux qui ont joué
à minecraft
on peut encore en faire avec de la red
stone ça marche très très bien
d'ailleurs accessoirement il ya eu il ya
même des mecs qui ont frais aussi à
faire un ordinateur dans le jeu ce que
je trouve aussi complètement dingue avec
minecraft et urine complet voilà donc
mieux aux colonisations de minecraft
turing complet s'était pas ultra sûre je
sais pas si c'était volontaire d'arriver
à faire ce genre de comportement mais à
partir du moment où
tu peux faire un nom et 1 et j'ai quand
même dans le jeu est très très facile à
faire
c'est bon là du coup tu peux tout faire
et étrangers donc là du coup donc à ces
opérateurs là est en fait les portes
logiques c'est la c1 moyens matériels de
faire ces éléments là donc ils font du
coup par exemple dans le cas des
ordinateurs maintenant on va utiliser un
ensemble de transistors qu'on va
connecter les uns aux autres pour être
capable de faire cesser ces portes
logiques
ouais mais du coup avec ça on peut faire
toutes ces réactions peuvent toujours de
faire des additions qu'un professeur
d'éducation ont fait on peut faire
toutes sortes de véhicules cska s'est
faite dans les ordinateurs si mes
souvenirs sont bons à peu de choses près
on a tous voir une immense majorité de
ce qu'on appelle des nand donc des notes
end
et avec ça avec juste non et on pourrait
tout calculer ce cas ces feux c'est
vraiment ça c'est un truc ça c'est quand
vous avez des trucs alors on a rien là
dessus pour moi pour le coup j'ai il
faut que j'arrive à me renseigner sur le
cantique parce que je suis pas sûr
d'avoir fait typiquement je me sens pas
vraiment légitime de parler de san jose
pas trop à l'aborder en exposer ce que
je sens que vision de là je veux dire
n'importe quoi donc je me méfie c'est un
jeu n'était pas facile même s'il est
quand même super super intéressant c'est
moi je faut faire je prenne le temps de
me renseigner parce que c'est vraiment
un truc assez assez cool quoi on ya une
vidéo qui va sortir sur la chaîne string
theory où je vais parler de dia une je
parle un peu des ordinateurs avec un
flic mais faisons très vulgariser et une
autre où je parle de façon un peu moins
vulgariser de l'algorithme de chopes
legros algorithmes quantique à celui qui
la factorisation dénombre pour moi je
regarderai à la safer le début de mes
connaissances sur ce domaine là savaient
très bien ce que du coup les ordinateurs
quantiques souvent la merde sont décrits
soit aujourd'hui c'est c'est plus avec
des portes logiques avec des codes autre
chose de fou que tu as appris au cours
des deux dernières années on va dire
je dirais le menace c'est tellement
faire un truc qui apprend tout seul sans
toucher un brin d'informatique
je trouve ça juste monstrueux quoi
d'ailleurs à leurs réseaux de neurones
himalaya va pas attendre grand chose je
pensais qu'elle tient une ou des
itérations et si ça se passe bien c'est
un gag mais ce qu'il faut être le
menacer qu'en fait il faut pas
totalement d'itérations pour pouvoir
commencer à avoir des résultats sympas
quoi je crois que donald ricci le mec
qui a inventé ça il disait alors j'y
crois pas trop mais il disait que à
partir de 20 et ération ça commençait à
devenir intéressant la partie je crois
pas trop on fait ça me paraît un peu
abusé mais à partir de 50 ça commence à
devenir sympa c'est il n'en faut pas
énormément quoi peut-être d'un projet de
mettre en place un belge auteur j'ai
déjà fait toutes les boîtes j'ai tilté
toutes les boîtes les 304 boîte j'ai
passé trois jours mais c'est bon c'est
fait maintenant j'ai mes boîtes c'est la
juste la grosse galère c'était les
transporter évidemment 3 103 104 boîte
indépendante ben pour l'instant il reste
dans mon armoire et quand je veux faire
tester mes collègues quand je fais
entrer nelly abel j'ouvre mon armoire et
ils viennent dans mon bureau est-ce que
tu as pris des grosses bottes du coup
non j'ai pris des trucs assez petit
d'ailleurs je pense que mes perles sont
un peu trop grosse par rapport à la
taille de la boîte
donc c'est pas impossible que je doive
changer les perles mettre des trucs
beaucoup plus petit mais voilà non il
faut quand même un peu de place et je
voulais pas non plus avoir des bois trop
grosse parce que sinon ça devient
ingérable pour passer à pas parler d'un
autre sujet comment vas-tu le futur papa
noms de l'informatique pour commencer
positif en termes de technologie je
pense que ce qu'on va développer ça va
être vraiment ça va être vraiment cool
la seule crainte que j'ai c'est que
l'informatique va le numérique de
manière générale coûte absolument un
prix délirants en termes déjà de
fabrication de machines ça utilise des
matériaux relativement rares etc
qui sont pas forcément bien recyclés
donc ça limite quand même pas mal la
progression de 28 en un futur à moyen
moyen long terme quoi là pour l'instant
on est plutôt tranquille et surtout la
consommation globaux saumoneaux
d'internet
ça ça me fait un peu flipper à vrai dire
et là qu'au niveau cloud et écologique
on n'est pas top
et là en plus internet progressant la
consommation augmente aussi
et alors je sais j'ai plus chiffres en
tête mais je crois que c'est pour pour
alimenter la totalité d'internet c'est
plusieurs centrales nucléaires du mal à
se rendre compte parce que pendant une
petite téléphone dans notre coin notre
sens c'est un petit netflix tranquille
et puis et puis en fait on se rend on a
du mal à se rendre compte que ben le
streaming ça a causé en termes de
comptes de consommation électrique c'est
absolument monstrueux donc voilà je le
vois donc j'aurai plutôt positif en
termes de technologie mais j'ai un peu
peur des conséquences que ça peut avoir
sur l'environnement et du coup par
conséquent si on a plus de matériaux
pour faire quoi que ce soit et c'est sur
fond rouge absents quand on est en train
de monter vers un âge d'or et puis on va
finir par avoir un peu de mal derrière
quoi sauf si on trouve des solutions qu
est ok et au delà de l'informatique 1
quand tu vois que tu es au delà de
l'informatique quand tu vois le futur je
suis plutôt optimiste
ouais c'est globalement en fait sur un
pousseur un peu touche plutôt optimiste
je me dis qu'on va réussir à récupérer
notre planète
il ya certains qui ont traité de
vraiment très très optimiste trop
optimiste peut-être mais ward est ce que
tu as d'autres choses à rajouter dessus
que tu abordé non en particulier comme
ça qui me vient en tête
ok ok quel message clé tu aimerais que
les ivoires les auditeurs retiennent de
ce podcast et intéressez vous à tous
c'est en gros quand j'ai découvert la
halle tout le tout la communauté du
l'égalisation française je me suis
intéressé à plein de trucs et ça m'a
ouvert des portes et des connaissances
sur plein d'autres choses et grosso modo
cc je trouve ces ultras enrichissant en
fait de pas se contenter
de son domaine à soit là typiquement
même et encore moi j'avais déjà j'étais
déjà plus risible nerfs dans mes études
mais le fait de commencer à m'intéresser
à d'autres choses comme le droit
l'économie des trucs qui en gros j'en ai
gens n'avaient absolument rien à faire
avant du coup ça me touche ça m'apporte
vraiment c'est assez enrichissant de
vraiment s'ouvrir à plein d'autres trucs
surtout que même dans son propre domaine
le fait de s'ouvrir à d'autres choses
ça peut amener des idées ça peut amener
des intuitions qui peut vraiment faire
évoluer sa propre pensée sur son propre
domaine d exploser au palais qui
essaient de faire le lien entre
l'informatique et d'autres données alors
le l'exposé sur la modélisation c'est un
peu l'idée dansant ou évidemment quand
on va mobiliser on va mobiliser quelque
chose donc on va utiliser l'informatique
dans d'autres domaines il ya un peu ça
et en arrivant au palais moi je me suis
fixé comme objectif de faire un exposé
avec toutes les unités
donc en gros avec la physique la chimie
la géologie les maths sont les maths
c'est assez évident on peut faire des
liens parce que c'est on est un peu là
le domaine le domaine fils d des
mathématiques mais voilà du cool avec
l'astro avec un peu un peu tous les
domaines l'histoire de vraiment montrer
que l'informatique est partout et que
toulon utilisent skype et dur alors pour
moi avec mes connaissances à moi j'ai du
mal à voir avec la chimie alors je sais
je sais pas du tout comment c'est
aborder dans quels domaines quelles sont
les questions qu'on va pouvoir faire
qu'on va pouvoir aborder avec le côté
chimie donc ça je sais que en discutant
avec avec les légendes de l'unité de
chimie voire même avec brucy corps qui
est monsieur schmitt dans le café des
sciences
je vais pouvoir trouver des liens entre
l'informatique et la chimie mais je me
fais pas trop de souci là-dessus il va à
pompe a par contre par rapport à la bio
étant donné que j'ai fait j'ai fait
toute une partie de mon cursus en
biologie je vois parfaitement les liens
de chez plein plein d'idées ok mais j'ai
un peu quand
alors que tu sais que que turing evans
nomades ont commencé par faire de chimie
turinois si si je me trompe pas j'avais
pas ça il vaut nomades qui est aussi
l'un des pères de l'informatique
d'accord c'est non alors peut-être que
je me trompe sur twingo je sais que nash
aussi par contre ça il me semble que ça
samedi quelque chose effectivement ces
longs mois présence ils ont peut-être
mal commencé mais ont bien fini
voilà ça c'est pas laissez pas le
laissez pas les plus les plus méconnus
c'est sûr est ce que tu vas finir avec
deux recommandent pas avec des
recommandations de deux vidéos podcasts
et olivo personnes à suivre
alors moi je voudrais commander une
chaîne youtube de vulgarisation endroit
n a pas beaucoup et c'est là elle est
particulièrement pas connu c'est joris
planète
alors il a fait une petite pause il a
fait une petite pause pour des raisons
personnelles mais là en fait il va
reprendre un petit peu les vidéos il va
refaire des choses
et franchement j'ai jamais vu la juriste
la jurisprudence présenté comme ça c'est
absolument génial
ok je vous conseille vraiment sa chaîne
et en notre recommandation aux ressorts
un petit peu de la science j'ai envie de
parler d'eux une chaîne s'appelle my
brother's qui est une chaîne de demain
d'un petit groupe de vidéastes du sud
qui fait des petits courts-métrages des
trucs très sympa très travaillée
complètement style années 80 avec un
style rétro un peu à un peu pellicule
abîmé et c'est super sympa si vous aimez
bien ce style un peu années 80 c'est il
s'est super bien foutu ok très bien
excellent ben merci beaucoup emilien
d'oriens merci à toi maman de m'avoir un
interview et merci aux eater d'avoir
suivi et je vous dis à prochaine fois
probablement
profite pour parler un peu de l'accueil
du palais de la découverte ou travailler
millien qui va fermer pour rénovation en
septembre 2020 et du coup va y avoir un
bâtiment temporaire dans le 15e donc je
vous mets un peu les informations dans
les descriptions en dessous mais du coup
si vous voulez voir les expositions
notamment dans l'informatique et des
millions auprès des couleurs
dépêchez-vous alesi avant septembre 2020
et par ailleurs d'après le projet actuel
de rénovation du ps découverte il y
aurait une réduction a priori des
effectifs et des salles prévue pour 2024
donc pour la suite du palais de la
découverte
et ça ça voudrait dire beaucoup moins
d'offres en termes de vulgarisation
scientifique en ce merveilleux bâtiment
qu'est le palais découverte et pour
éviter cette réduction de l'offre de
vulgarisation scientifique sur paris je
mets un petit lien vers une pétition qui
a été lancée pour défendre la culture
scientifique dans ce merveilleux
bâtiment qui est le palais du commerce
si vous ne connaissez pas je vous
recommande vivement d'y aller je trouve
personnellement que ce qui est exposé au
palais et d'une qualité extrêmement rare
que l'on trouve difficilement tant
d'autres musées de sciences
la pétition a déjà presque 4000
signataires au moment où j'enregistre
cette interview mais du coup je vous
invite vivement à apporter votre
contribution à cette pétition pour la
protection du palais de découverte